we all know this scene don't we
a sunny morning on a quiet ordinary
looking neighborhood street ah but it's
no ordinary day for the little girl who
lives in this house
something special something exciting is
happening to her
it's her birthday
and here's the mailman with a handful of
messages for Alice birthday cards sent
by her relatives friends and Playmates
among them is one special one very very
special birthday card because you see
today Alice is three
[Music]
what's so extra special about this
birthday card
well listen to what it says
happy birthday
hey I hear you are three years old at
least ways that's what I've been told
three is a wonderful age to be you're
very important when you are three
there is something you should do now
that you're much more than two see your
dentist right away make sure your teeth
are all okay
a very special birthday message indeed
now that Alice is more than two it is
vitally important that she make her
first visit to the dentist
Alice's mother explains that the best
time to make an appointment with the
dentist is right now if we put it off
until tomorrow we might forget
Alice's mother is a conscientious parent
who safeguards the health of her child
every day in every way by proper diet
plenty of sleep and frequent medical and
dental checkups she realizes that
Alice's teeth are tremendously important
to her Total Health
Betty suggests that she send Alice's
mother literature prepared by the
American Dental Association which helps
parents prepare their child for the
important first visit to the dental
office
Betty checks her appointment book and
finds a convenient time for Alice's
first visit two weeks from today
Alice's mother also learns from Betty
that parents can almost guarantee their
children sound healthy teeth and gums
for a Lifetime by following a program of
regular Dental checkups and by
practicing sound Dental Health
procedures in the home
doctor friend will explain to Mother
exactly which Dental Health safeguards
should be followed
ordinarily little children have no fear
of the dentist unless they are taught to
fear by adults or older children
mother and Alice have talked about the
interesting new experience of visiting
Dr friend
mother has explained why it is so
important to visit the dentist regularly
as a result Alice is looking forward
eagerly to her first appointment with Dr
friend
and what do you know
mother was right look at this a regular
playroom and all these picture books oh
this is fun thanks Alice
but now it's time for Betty the dental
assistant to take Alice into the dental
office
mother remains in the waiting room
some dentists prefer to examine a child
without the parent standing by
however because parents and dentists
must work together to assure children a
lifetime of Smiles Dr friend will talk
with Mother later and explain to her the
various aspects of Alice's daily dental
health program in the home
meanwhile Alice is learning all about
the dental office from Betty however
Mother after having read American Dental
Association pamphlets has already taught
Alice a great deal about dental office
procedures and equipment and the
professional uniforms worn by the
dentist and his assistant
when Dr friend meets Alice he knows how
vitally important it is that this first
visit be pleasant for it will influence
her attitude toward dental care for the
rest of her life
while Betty prepares Alice for her
dental examination Dr friend enters his
outer office for his first conference
with mother
Today's Dentist does much more than
merely repair decayed teeth and treat
various gum diseases he acts to prevent
dental health problems before they begin
he functions as a dental health educator
instructing parents on how they can keep
their children's teeth and gums sound
and healthy by following proper Dental
Health procedures in the home
Dr friend informs Alice's mother that
the first dental examination of a child
should take place by the time all 20
primary teeth are in the mouth
generally when the child is between two
and a half and three years old
occasionally a child younger than two
and a half must see a dentist about 50
percent of all two and a half year old
children show evidence of decay in one
or more primary teeth
Dr friend using a mouth mirror and an
Explorer carefully examines each of
Alice's teeth
he reports whatever defects he finds to
his assistant Who records them on
Alice's Dental chart
it is important for parents to know that
each tooth has five surfaces and that
decay may occur on any or all of the
five sides
however the dentist does much more than
just examine teeth
Dr friend examines the tissues of
Alice's mouth
he checks her bite that is the alignment
of her teeth
he examines her glands for any Tell-Tale
swelling that may be caused by infected
teeth
and there is one more extremely
important step that Dr friend will take
before completing Alice's Dental
examination and diagnosis
using only his mouth mirror and Explorer
the dentist cannot be expected to detect
all tooth defects in order to make
absolutely certain that no hidden
cavities lurked between Alice's teeth Dr
friend takes X-ray pictures
scientific studies show that without the
aid of x-rays the dentist misses a
certain amount of beginning Decay tiny
spots of Decay that can rapidly become
large cavities if not treated
immediately
with today's modern equipment and
protective measures dental X-rays are a
safe and essential procedure for a
Complete Dental diagnosis
once more Dr friend consults with Mother
explaining some of the findings in
Alice's Dental examination
most particularly he wishes to call her
attention to the location of the first
permanent molar known as the six-year
molar because it will appear in Alice's
mouth about the time she is six years
old an important tooth and one of the
most neglected dental records show it to
be the most diseased tooth in the mouth
parents should watch carefully for the
six-year molar to erupt that is grow
through the Gump parents should pay
careful attention to its care if this
permanent six-year molar is ever lost no
other tooth will grow in to replace it
Dr friend wishes to make certain that
Alice's mother knows exactly where to
look for the important six-year molar
when it begins growing through the gum
tissue in Alice's mouth
it will appear
there just behind the last primary molar
while Alice's x-rays are being developed
doctor friend and mother resume their
talk
he explains that primary teeth are
extremely important for chewing speech
and appearance
primary or baby teeth have much to do
with the condition of the permanent
teeth which will grow in later
many primary teeth remain in the mouth
for 11 or 12 years they must be
maintained in a healthy condition until
they are replaced by permanent teeth
Dental studies show that generally if
primary teeth are maintained in a sound
healthy condition the permanent teeth
which follow will also be sound and
healthy should a child either through
accident or neglect lose his primary
teeth too early his speech may be
handicapped
these twins because their front teeth
are missing have developed poor speech
habits and they are undergoing speech
therapy to correct them
naturally every child is without his
front teeth for a short time
normally however permanent teeth grow in
quickly to fill the vacant space
teeth are vitally necessary for good
appearance
loss of even one front tooth can
radically alter a person's appearance
whenever a primary tooth is lost earlier
than it should either through accident
or neglect the teeth on either side will
tend to lean or drift into the open
space closing it up making it difficult
or impossible for the permanent tooth to
grow in later
because like a rotten apple in a barrel
a decayed tooth may cause other teeth to
Decay it often must be removed by the
dentist a space maintainer as seen here
keeps the space left by the missing
tooth open
this x-ray picture also shows the
permanent tooth growing beneath the gum
when it is ready to erupt through the
gum the space maintainer will be removed
what causes tooth decay
bacteria which are found in everyone's
mouth feed on sugar to produce a
powerful acid which attacks and destroys
tooth enamel
therefore sugar is the greatest enemy of
teeth
each time a child or an adult eats a
meal or snack he consumes a certain
amount of sugar
immediately the mouth bacteria begin
feeding upon the sugar and rapidly
producing acid
acid can go to work on tooth enamel as
quickly as three minutes after eating
and this acid action can last as long as
90 minutes
notice the Peaks and valleys on the
chart held by Dr friend notice that acid
formation in the mouth Rises sharply
after each meal that same condition
occurs following between meal snacks
it's easy to see that each time a child
consumes candy cake pie cookies or other
sweets this Decay action begins
automatically and almost immediately
the dental profession does not wish to
condemn children to a sweetless
existence however the wise parent
controls the amount of sweets eaten by
children by substituting foods with less
sugar content
for example for between meal snacks in
place of sugary cookies
give tasty crackers or deviled eggs
which have a high food value
in place of sugar saturated drinks offer
them fruit juices and milk which are far
more nourishing
or try the traditional American hot dog
Which is far less sugary for example
than a jelly peanut butter sandwich
apples are excellent snack food and they
help clean teeth while being eaten
by substituting nourishing foods such as
these for sweets parents can cut the
Decay rate of their children's teeth
substantially
however parents must do more they must
make certain that their children brush
their teeth regularly
Dr friend informs Alice's mother that
the toothbrush properly used is the best
weapon in the daily fight against tooth
decay
brush teeth as they grow
upper teeth downward lower teeth upward
give each tooth 10 Strokes brush front
back and top of each tooth work bristles
between teeth to remove debris Lodge
there
remember Decay action can begin as soon
as three minutes after eating so brush
immediately after each meal or snack if
one cannot brush each time rinse the
mouth vigorously with water to wash away
food particles clinging to teeth
remove the food particles that stick to
teeth and Lodge between them and the
bacteria in the mouth starve
they then cannot produce the acid which
attacks and destroys teeth
even at three Alice is old enough to
brush her teeth properly but only under
the watchful eye of her mother
surprisingly enough many individuals
don't know the proper toothbrushing
technique and knowing it can prevent
much tooth decay any dentist is happy to
demonstrate
mother will have Alice practice at home
so that she knows how
Alice's x-rays are now ready for viewing
they show Dr friend that Alice has some
small areas of beginning tooth decay
between the teeth
it is important for parents to realize
as Alice's mother does that without the
aid of X-ray the tiny beginning Decay
areas in a child's teeth probably will
escape detection by the dentist
dental decay knows no age many two and a
half and three-year-old children already
have beginning Decay which can spread
quickly causing a large cavity
filling tiny cavities at once halts
Decay saves costly repairs later
compare Alice's x-rays with ease of a
four-year-old note the developing
permanent teeth growing down from above
but is this a sad picture of neglect
rampant Decay has all but destroyed
these primary teeth
mother asks what else can be done to
assure Alice the best in dental health
there is one more dental procedure that
will help Alice the proper use of
fluorides
your dentist will advise you regarding
the type of treatment he recommends in
accordance with the type of fluoride he
uses
Alice should have her first topical
treatment now
today however the most effective and
safe Health measure to combat tooth
decay is the daily ingestion of the
recommended amount of fluoride in
drinking water
it is most beneficial during the growing
period of the teeth
now Alice's first dental examination is
completed
and as a reward for good behavior Dr
friend gives her an apple one of the
recommended snack foods low in sugar
the important Dental Health steps for
parents to follow are these regular
visits to the dentist beginning at age
three as Alice did
control the amount of sweets eaten sugar
destroys teeth substitute non-sugary
foods for between meal snacks
proper tooth brushing immediately after
each meal or snack
making the best use of fluorides by
drinking Community water with the
recommended fluoride content and topical
treatment of a fluoride Solution by a
dentist to the teeth
yes Alice is three
a fortunate little girl because her
mother and her dentist are working
together to safeguard her dental health
children born today whose parents follow
the dentist's prescribed measures can be
sure of sound healthy teeth and gums
throughout their childhood and if these
children as they grow to adulthood
continue to follow proper Dental Health
procedures they can count on keeping
their permanent teeth in a healthy
condition for life
yes indeed the dental profession offers
today's youngsters a lifetime of smiles
thank you
[Music]